[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
make way for the espn national
correspondent covering the nfl
sao palantonio his 29th training camp
and uh joins us on the programs what's
the what's the big takeaway from last
night's game
well dan i think the biggest headline
was provided by jerry jones he did an
impromptu presser
right after i talked to mike mccarthy on
sportscenter jones talked to the dallas
media kind of stuck my nose in there and
i asked him uh
what kind of advice or you know i know
you're not close to your players
especially doc
and he's and he
when he talked about dax injury
and about how cautious they are being
he reached up under his
arm
and pointed to his lat muscle
uh confirming that dax injury is not
necessarily a shoulder or an elbow or an
arm issue that he has a strained lat
on the right side and he also confirmed
that it happened when he threw
a long hail mary pass in practice or you
know before practice started when he got
done the day he got hurt
and as you know from a lat injury
it's it's all about rest
because it can impact your shoulder your
arm your back your hip
everything
and with that coming back from that
gruesome leg injury it's all about rest
and icing it and getting some
stimulation but the basic bottom line is
you read anything about it you get any
kind of advice from a doctor they'll
tell you to do nothing until it's
completely healed how much pressure do
you think we love to rank things people
but as far as individuals with pressure
on them where does dak prescott rank in
your opinion
pretty near top of the list right um got
the money uh he's got a lot of uh
components around him they've invested a
lot in this team changed head coaches
kept his offensive coordinator
uh
obviously the the gruesome leg injury
that he suffered in week five last year
resulted in the team going six and ten
when they were on their way i mean the
offense looks so good
and i really like dak i think he's super
tough uh he's obviously a very smart and
capable player but he's just a great
leader
zach is one of the great leaders that we
have in the nfl dan
and i think he's going to come out of
this he
is totally
committed to making sure that the injury
is 100 percent he understands he's heard
from the team that coaches the doctors
that this is the kind of injury
where if you you know are not fully
healed and you re-injure it it could
really last for weeks and weeks on end
you sat down with ben roethlisberger
what was the big takeaway from that
well ben's 39 and he's basically hitting
the reset button like tom brady i mean
brady did it when he was 43
went to a new team had a new offensive
new offensive coordinator and here's
bennett 39 new offensive coordinator new
offense
matt canada
is the new offensive coordinator and the
dictum from rooney on down is we will
run the football you know when you're
last in the league
and running the ball and they were way
last in the league by a wide margin ban
and play action pass
and so
if you're last in the league and running
the ball and you're not providing any
deception at all out of your running
game then they're just coming after you
everybody knew they were going to throw
it and they just ran out of gas
as for how he looked i thought he looked
excellent
i really did the ball had great
trajectory
the ball had terrific accuracy deep and
short ben's a great passer
his movement which is always great
subtle in the pocket looked good i was
there on the day they were hitting he
wasn't touched obviously
but that was a day where you know the
energy was high and
i thought that he really looked good and
he sounded good and he understands what
he's up against he really does he's
taken it year by year he's got one year
weeks
i believe
yeah i wondered if they didn't think
they could get a quarterback they wanted
or they just didn't like the
quarterbacks that were going to be
available and that's why they decided to
stay with ben
well i think they decided to stay with
ben because he's a two-time super bowl
check and then he gives them their best
option
yeah but you guys think start thinking
about the future here if you're
pittsburgh
you do and then you you definitely do
and um you know they do have they did
bring in dwayne haskins he's a
reclamation project
and if anybody can reach him it's mike
tomlin
and they were saying all the right
things about him now i watched him in
practice
watched him very closely last night
and when i watched him in practice they
were implementing some of the stuff that
he was doing last night over and over
again canada had him rolling to his left
and throwing outside the pocket moving
the so-called platform the launch
platform for him
uh you know partially that is because
they've had some problems
you know protecting the passer and the
other thing is they like his athleticism
and he's turned into a very good
passer outside the pocket on the move
so
um you know they're working with them to
try to see how committed he is to the
game how is how he will take the
coaching
how we will pick up this offense
and you know he's got the best and the
best to learn from i mean i just have a
high regard for mike tomlin i think he's
one of the best coaches all time in the
nfl
well he's a hall of famer if bill cower
is going in the hall of fame then so is
mike tomlin
and so is ben roethlisberger and i'm a
voter and you know that and i will vote
first ballot for both of them
would you take a look i don't know how
this works is it the veterans committee
that kenny anderson and ken riley who
played for the bengals
i i
i don't have any i mean i have a
platform but i'm not a voter uh but i
i'm just curious how that works with
with players like that of just getting
the attention of the voters and say
is anybody talking about them has
anybody spoke on their behalf
there's a huge pool of senior candidates
and both of them are in it okay
and it's you know their names come up
there's definitely legitimate discussion
about both
i can tell you from a personal
standpoint i'm a big believer in kenny
anderson i think kenny anderson should
be in the hall of fame
i mean i don't know what the debate will
be about riley but i think anderson has
been overlooked for way too long and
should be in
do you have any hesitation voting for
eli manning
none
okay
none whatsoever i think um you know i'll
vote for him right from the start and
he'll there'll be a a a discussion about
him for sure but eli manning is going to
the hall of fame
eli man he's going to get in i don't
know if it's going to be first ballot
might be a little bit of a struggle for
the first year or two
because of the debate that will go on
about his career but i will vote for him
right away and i will push hard for him
to go in
and he should go in and he will go in
talking to sal palantonio from the
mothership
give me
give me the player who's not in who
should be
oh boy who's not in who should be uh
that would have to be tony bicelli
okay
i think tony beselly you know is
obviously his injury history with that
shoulder
and the length of service that he had
but we set a president with terrell
davis
with td with the broncos yeah and
beselly
the silly dan i mean i don't have to
tell you when you watched pacelli he was
just better than everybody
in his era
shut down bruce smith
um he was just
great
and
he's very close
very close
to getting in
and and i'm not going to make a
prediction because it's a very
unpredictable room
and you never know what's going to
happen with the vote
but i think tony beselli has a very good
shot of getting in this year or next
any uh whispers with desean watson you
being based in philadelphia i i don't
know if the eagles are completely sold
on jalen hurts doesn't seem like it but
um
what are the odds do you think that they
take a run at desean watson well the
beautiful thing about working for espn
is i got chris mortensen and adam
schechter
so i'm going to let them handle that
that's way beyond my pay grade
as far as deshaun watson but i will tell
you this about genuine hurts i was there
last friday i talked to nick siriani
one-on-one and i talked to jalen it was
the first one-on-one interview he did
and i watched him in practice
so he's trying
to get his feet under him in nick
ciriani's offense
and jalen is a tremendous athletic
talent who last year
was on a pace to put out some great
numbers now his completion percentage i
understand was below 60 percent but
that's just such a small sample size
four games that was such a tremendous
pressure cooker situation with covet 19
and carson wentz getting hurt and all of
the controversy surrounding carson wentz
so jalen hurts was thrown into the fire
and passed all of the tests passed the
eye test
passed the leadership test
passed a teammate test was embraced by
his teammates
and jalen hurts right now he's trying to
you've got a new coach and a new system
it's going to be run heavy they want him
to be more of a pocket passer
you saw the comments he made last week
where he said he's learning to
appreciate what the coaches want him to
do
while not sacrificing his athleticism
and what are those code words for hey
i'm learning how to be a pocket pastor
but i want to show off what i can do
i'll leave you with this our poll
question today is not who's the best
quarterback second best quarterback in
nfl history who is the third best
quarterback of all time in your opinion
uh bart starr
so i'm going to go uh did i shock in
amazia yeah i did i think yeah yeah i i
i'm going montana brady
and bardstar i think martin is the
all-time greatest
um if i had a game to win
it would be montana you've got a game
the championship game it would be joe
montana tom brady would be number two
okay and then bart starr look at his
postseason numbers and record
his his efficiency and production in the
postseason and that offense
was amazing and he had in my view the
most iconic
quarterback sneak in football history
and the great thing about it as we now
have found out is that he audible that
the line of scrimmage he was supposed to
hand it off that chuck mercedes decided
not to do that and went in and on his
own
loved that story
yeah
selfish me first
wanted all the glory
right
just like bart starr's personality yeah
exactly yeah exactly he was the john
glenn uh of the nfl in the 60s and a
brief story very brief
i was with it i was in a restaurant in
atlanta in a super bowl and i don't
remember what year it was darth star was
quietly having breakfast with his wife
and every time she left the table he
stood
up helped her out of her chair
and then when she came back to the table
he stood up
and put her back in her chair and pushed
it back in he was just the consummate
gentleman even when nobody was looking
that's what the danettes do for me when
i get up from the table they stand up
and then when i i come back and and it's
not they don't do it on their own i
basically order them that that you stand
up and then when i come back then they
all help me with my chair
that's sweet yes it is very very
heartwarming very heartwarming and by
the way i don't know if you had uh any
vote on this but thank you to whoever
voted on the roselle award with john
fasenda because i i made it a mission
that i i i just wanted people to
you know just
let's re-examine this and the fact that
steve sable's going in his father's
already in and i just thought you know
make it a trilogy that john fasenda
deserved to be in the uh pro football
hall of fame so i'm i'm uh i think it's
uh wonderful he'll be honored tonight
why did it take so long
i don't think i thought that he was in
sal and then i said to mclovin i said
would you check and see if john fasenda
is in he goes he's not i go we're
writing a letter and i wrote a letter to
david baker and i just said just just
bring this up so people know that john
fasenda is not in the hall of fame and
he said that he would and um you know
it's it's awesome that john
you know that voice will be heard on
those loudspeakers tonight and it will
bring back a lot of memories for a lot
of people there and it'll be great
it was the voice of god and it was the
soundtrack of our lives yeah yeah that's
awesome uh have fun this weekend always
great to catch up with you sal thanks
for joining us
thank you for having me on the program
dan that's sao palantonio the mothership
always great to uh talk to sao